. Let's go to Andrew from Miami,
Andrew from Miami. You're on the air.
Hi, David. Yes, I can.
Hey, so I was wondering
what your thoughts are on the Jimmy Door versus
AMC discussion that's been going on on Twitter?
No, I'm not. What what is what's going on now?
I mean, I think it's pretty important and
pretty interesting to talk about is Jimmy Door is
currently trying to argue that AMC and the squad
should force Nancy Pelosi to put a House vote
on Medicare for all by basically refusing to
vote for her for speaker of the House. OK. And
I think it would really do a lot in forcing the
House to actually put that to a vote and bring it
into the national spotlight, as opposed to just
giving in to Nancy Pelosi's standard demands
of making her speaker like we do every time.
Does does Nancy Pelosi need the four
votes from the squad to become speaker?
So the the squad actually consists of more
than just four people at this point. I mean,
the progressive caucus of the Democratic Parties
is around a hundred people, but like you.
But the squad is not one hundred people. I
mean, maybe the squad is like six or eight
if you include some of the new people coming
in. So is is the claim that that four to eight
people should abstain from voting for Nancy
Pelosi or that the entire Progressive Caucus?
Yes, so.
The entire progressive caucus would be great,
but obviously not all of them are actually
progressive, they're just sort of to a name.
I guess I'm wondering what leverage
four to eight members of Congress
have to stop Nancy Pelosi from being speaker.
I just don't have the math in front of me.
Yeah, the math turns out to be actually
that it would be a pretty close vote.
And even some members of the Progressive Caucus
have admitted that the vote could come down to
as close as, you know, two to five votes if some
people aren't there for covid reasons, et cetera.
So there's actually some power in the hands of the
progressives in house. And so push the goal of.
So they do a vote and then.
And then what?
I guess the vote then the vote would show
that these are the people who are against
Medicare for all during a national pandemic. OK,
bring this current crisis where three thousand
people are dying per day, almost 300000 have
already died. And these people are against
voting for that guaranteed health care during that
pandemic. And we've also seen during this last
election that everybody who supported
Medicare for all won their runoff election.
So, yes, that's true. There is significant self
selection bias in saying that because you have
to look at, well, where did people in what what
were the races in which people were running with
that position? So I think there's a bit of reverse
engineering problem there, a chicken egg problem.
But more importantly, don't don't we I mean,
like, I'm fine with votes for whatever,
you know, do whatever votes people want
to do. I think it's great. Don't we know
who's for and against Medicare for all? Like
aren't members of Congress on the record?
Isn't the current vice president on the record
having been for Medicare for all? And then she
turned around and said that she's not. So it
seems like it's currently just for people to
be for it. Oh, you mean the president?
The vice president elect, you mean.
Yes. I mean, when people when it's advantageous
for people to be for it, therefore. Yeah. And
then when they're in positions of power, they're
suddenly against fighting for it. So I think
that's an interesting, you know, conundrum there.
And I mean, listen, I think it's fine to do that.
But it it seems also like either way, it's a
political posturing thing to like make a list
of names of who's been naughty and nice sort of.
And and then the problem is it's not going to do
anything for anybody. Like, it will literally
get us no closer to getting everybody coverage
or a coronavirus stimulus or saving a business
that's about to go out of business. So, like,
I have no you know, the house can do whatever
it wants and sure do it. I don't know that they
have the leverage to even get Nancy Pelosi to do
it. And even if they do, it's a Beltway story in
the sense that people who right now are about to
lose their business or not pay their mortgage,
they don't benefit by getting a list of members
of Congress that were hypocritical on Medicare
for all. Would I be curious? I guess, but
I just don't know that we really are doing
anything for the people by making that the focus.
And remember, I haven't seen any of what you're
talking about on Twitter. I'm just taking you at
your word that you're describing it accurately.
Interesting. Yeah. Dimitar is trending
over the weekend about it. And there was
on Rising and a few other programs as well.
OK, yeah, that's I guess that's probably why
I didn't see it. I don't watch other programs
and I didn't look at Twitter over the weekend.
Gotcha. All right. All right.
Thank you very much. Appreciate that.